my first thought when I saw the new 2019
iPad air show up in Apple's website was
wow that's basically a 2017 iPad pro but
with fewer features so I recommended
that instead of the new air but since
then I've realized that not everyone
wants I used a refurbished two year old
iPad and although the a 10x chip in the
iPad pro will last many years the a12
and the new iPad air will last longer in
its fresh and brand-new I've realized
that the $500 price tag really isn't
that bad for what you get considering
that the extra power of the 2018 iPad
pro won't be noticed unless you're doing
something like video editing we played
games on both iPads and didn't really
notice a difference in available
graphics quality and smoothness of
gameplay both of them could easily play
certain games at 60 frames per second
and even pub G at maxed out graphics no
issues at all on the iPad air the 2019
iPad Mini packs the same 812 processor
as the iPad air but for $100 cheaper
which is a great deal if you're okay
with the smaller display and in my
review of the iPad Mini I called it the
best tablet ever for gaming even more so
than the new iPad pro because of the
lightweight and easy to hold form factor
the mini and air are basically identical
iPads except for two things
the size and the fact that the air gets
a smart connector for use with Apple's
high quality smart keyboard the Mini is
so small that typing on a Bluetooth
keyboard won't really be comfortable
other than that they're basically the
same exact iPad the displays are
absolutely fantastic and much better
than the 2018 budget iPads display
however the smaller display of the Mini
is definitely a drawback for certain
things so that's why it's worth it for
some people to spend the extra hundred
dollars for the iPad air if you're into
note-taking or drawing the minis display
is pretty limiting in that regard I
don't think people realize just how much
smaller the display is compared to the
iPad air the video content is much
smaller doing schoolwork or spreadsheets
may be a bit more difficult and you see
less on the screen while browsing the
web so the 2019 iPad air is a great
choice for those who need a larger
display but don't want to pay the extra
cash for the new iPad pro the biggest
problem is that iOS is currently very
limiting so you can't really use you
iPad as a computer replacement at least
not yet now let's take a look into the
future and see what we can expect
iOS 13 is going to be revealed soon and
it looks like there are some iPad
features coming that are going to boost
productivity and multitasking on the
iPad of course there's the rumored dark
mode feature but I want to focus on
productivity features for example it
looks like we're finally getting
multiple app window support so that
means you can have two instances of
different apps open at the same time
like Google Docs - Safari windows or -
spreadsheets and much more and you can
easily move them around the screen just
like you can do on a real computer also
Safari will be able to automatically ask
for a desktop version of certain sites
to avoid compatibility issues and we're
finally getting a real undo gesture
because who's going to be shaking their
iPad to undo text that's ridiculous
Apple's also rumored to be adding a new
font manager and they're making
improvements to document collaboration
and third-party apps the mail app is
getting some worthy desktop like
improvements as well and it seems like
Apple is finally going to add a way to
quickly select multiple items in various
views just like click and drag on Mac OS
as you can tell from these changes Apple
is really focusing on improving workflow
and allowing people to actually replace
their laptops much more easily now if
you're using these features and working
with multiple windows being limited to
the iPad minis display isn't going to be
fun that's why I think the air is going
to be the better choice for people who
use it for studying typing business work
or multitasking and we can look even
further at io s 14 and what features
that will be adding and I'm sure the
extra screen real estate will serve you
better in the years to come now if you
don't do much of that like let's say you
do a lot of gaming and you like the
portability of the iPad Mini then that's
still a great choice for some people
especially since you save $100 and
talking about the new iPad pro I still
think it's overkill for almost everyone
even after I was 13 and 14 are released
the 812 and the iPad air is a very
powerful chip and it will be more than
good enough for most people for years to
come now what are some of the drawbacks
of the 2019 iPad air well the main thing
is that still using the same old home
button packing design to me it's really
not that big of a deal the design still
looks
and works great another downside is that
it's still only packing two speakers on
the bottom
unlike four speakers on the iPad pro it
sucks but it makes sense why Apple would
keep that exclusively for the iPad pro
just like the pro motion technology
other than that there's really nothing
to complain about the iPad air it's a
fantastic all-around iPad that offers
basically everything you'll need to do
iPad things with an incredibly bright
and color accurate display so here's my
recommendation if you don't care much
for the iPad pros extra features and you
want to do some drawings note-taking
typing or multitasking I would
definitely buy the new iPad air over
every other iPad in Apple's 2019 iPad
lineup now if your budget is limited you
can pick up the 2018 budget iPad for
only around 250 to $280 brand-new but
you have to compromise on things like
display quality in a bit of performance
if you enjoyed this review
hit that button above to subscribe and
check out some of those in-depth iPad
comparison videos thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]